le point sur l'écho comme chaque jeudi
ce soir premier rendez-vous de l'écho
avec Claire Cambier et l'Echo
aujourd'hui c'est tout d'abord la
semaine du microcrédit qui va s'ouvrir
le 4 février oui voilà la semaine du
microcrédit se passe effectivement donc
du 4 au 8 février pour nous en parler
nous recevons Isabelle Treguer
responsable Yvelines de l'ADIL
l'Association pour le droit à
l'initiative aux économique et à
l'origine de cet événement et Noël Colin
responsable du pôle création reprise et
transmission à la Chambre des Métiers
puisque nous verrons que vous travaillez
ensemble sur ce projet on sera tous les
deux à mes côtés Céline cassis qui est
conseillère en création d'entreprises à
la BG des Yvelines c'est évidemment
aider Sylvie cordelet qui était l'invité
tout à l'heure la chef de cuisine
on vous retrouve en deuxième partie de
chronique pour les le concours talent de
la création d'entreprise
alors Isabelle Treguer c'est votre
association l'a dit qui a lancé la
semaine du microcrédit alors tout
d'abord l'a dit qu'est-ce que c'est
vraiment alors Lady c'est l'Association
pour le droit à l'initiative économique
c'est une association qui existe depuis
20 ans qui s'est inspiré de la
microfinance qui existe dans les pays en
voie de développement pour proposer un
outil de lutte contre le chômage
c'est-à-dire que par le microcrédit les
personnes créent leur entreprise leur
propre emploi et donc c'est un ça a été
inspiré effectivement c'est du dépays en
voie de développement vers les pays
industrialisés donc vers la France alors
comment ça se passe concrètement à qui
vous vous adressez pour quel type
d'entreprise alors on s'adresse à des
personnes qui sont en recherche d'emploi
depuis un certain temps donc des
demandeurs d'emploi des allocataires des
minima sociaux qui ne trouvent pas
d'emploi salarié et qui souhaitent créer
leur emploi qui se lancent et qui crée
leur entreprise c'est dans la plupart
des cas une entreprise individuelle ils
ont besoin d'un petit financement donc
d'un micro-crédit et l'a dit et là pour
les suivre et les accompagner et avec la
difficulté des banques justement pour
financer les difficultés pour les gens à
trouver des décrédients c'est ça se
multiplie les demandes pour les
microcrédits
professionnels on est là pour financer
un projet professionnel aujourd'hui donc
effectivement les banques ne suivent pas
forcément parce qu'on manque de
visibilité nous on a des petits montants
donc on peut se permettre de faire un
test d'activité dire que donc des
personnes qui
veulent se lancer peuvent se lancer avec
des petits moyens et vous prenez plus de
risques que les banques parce que vous
pouvez les absorber on prend plus de
risques pas parce qu'on peut les
absorber c'est parce qu'ensuite on va
accompagner les porteurs de projets on
va les aider à démarrer leur entreprise
et puis à développer leur activité pas
là que pour donner de l'argent
des montants faibles ça va jusqu'à 10000
euros c'est ça alors ça va jusqu'à 10000
euros mais en moyenne on prête 2000
euros et dans les enquêtes sur les
créateurs d'entreprise on voit que 19%
des créateurs d'entreprise démarre avec
moins de 2000 euros de financement au
départ et même certains sont financement
donc on s'adresse à des personnes qui
veulent créer vraiment leur emploi et
qui ont créé une petite entreprise vous
avez justement des exemples
d'entreprises créées de ce type oui
alors par exemple sur la zone de
Saint-Quentin on a financé cette année
un jeune pour une activité de de moto
taxi on a financé également une
boulangère qui a repris une activité et
puis beaucoup de commerces ambulants
c'est une activité de l'activité
commerce et dans un cas sur deux
l'activité que l'on finance alors est-ce
que vous savez tout au long de d'une
année combien de personnes vous aidez
alors cette année en 2012 on a financé
90 personnes on en a aidé plus parce que
en fait on accompagne davantage c'est à
dire que ce sont 90 nouvelles personnes
mais toutes celles qui ont un prêt on
les accompagne aussi donc au total on a
à peu près 160 personnes qu'on ait de
toute l'année et c'est des personnes qui
viennent d'elles-mêmes vous voir alors
elles peuvent venir d'elles-mêmes mais
beaucoup de personnes
n'osent pas venir nous voir n'osent pas
solliciter les structures
d'accompagnement parce que nous on
finance mais on s'appuie sur tous les
partenaires de la création d'entreprise
on s'appuie également sur les structures
d'insertion sur Pôle Emploi également
donc on travaille pour articuler les
différents dispositifs et donc il faut
qu'on fasse connaître c'est pour ça
qu'on fait la semaine du microcrédit
pour nous faire connaître notre action
ainsi que celle de nos partenaires donc
cette semaine justement mise en place
pour pour attirer les gens vers votre
structure des actions sont mises en
place dans la région et la chambre des
métiers qui participent ce collant
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus alors en fait on fait un
partenariat le jeudi 7 février de 13h30
à 16h30 dans les locaux de la Chambre de
Métiers à Versailles donc afin de
proposer au créateurs d'entreprise un
double rendez-vous à la fois à 10 et un
rendez-vous technique accompagnement
avec la chambre de métier donc l'idée
c'était de regrouper dans un seul lieu
un même moment les deux parties
c'est-à-dire accompagnement montage du
projet et deuxième partie le financement
c'est vrai que parfois on le fait en
deux étapes on le fait en deux moments
et là c'était de faire un moment rapide
et efficace et que à la fin de la
session on puisse trouver une solution
voilà donc le but c'est aussi de créer
un partenariat entre les deux structures
d'aller un peu plus loin
voilà en fait on a parlé beaucoup de
création d'entreprise mais la 10
s'adresse également aux personnes qui
sont déjà en activité dans les 5 ans de
leur activité et donc il y a des
entrepreneurs qui ont besoin également
de financement qui n'ont pas accès au
crédit bancaire ça peut être des
artisans qui dépendent de la chambre des
métiers et donc c'est une solution
également pour eux que on peut leur
apporter c'est pour ça que le
partenariat avec la Chambre des Métiers
est important parce que on peut ensemble
trouver les solutions pour pour les
artisans
est-ce qu'il y a donc d'autres d'autres
événements à venir alors il y a d'autres
événements à venir dont on va discuter
avec effectivement avec la chambre des
métiers dans l'année autour de des
entrepreneurs qui sont reçus la Chambre
des Métiers juste pour revenir sur ce
point tout type d'entrepreneurs peuvent
véritablement venir vous voir quel que
soit son domaine d'activité oui quel que
soit son domaine d'activité absolument
et quel est le domaine d'activité le
plus courant peut-être qu'on retrouve
alors là je vous ai dit donc pour les
Yvelines et puis sur sur
les Yvelines en général c'est le
commerce on a également les prestations
de services que ce soit à la personne ou
des prestations de service général
artisans également transports
ils nous arrivent de refuser parce que
un des éléments qu'on prend en compte
d'abord c'est la personne elle-même son
adéquation par rapport au projet le
projet ensuite et puis sa capacité à
rembourser il faut que l'activité lui
génère un revenu qui va lui permettre de
rembourser donc on refuse si on
considère qu'elle va prendre un risque
on refuse si la personne doit travailler
avantages son projet et dans ces cas là
on l'a réoriente vers les partenaires de
la création d'entreprise c'est difficile
de dire non c'est mal vécu comment ça se
passe vous faites ça en douceur et voilà
c'est un accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise et c'est aussi un
accompagnement à la non création donc
c'est ça humaine derrière tout ça c'est
vrai qu'on parle d'argent voilà mais une
dimension humaine voilà bien sûr donc
les c'est notre métier c'est de dire
parfois il faut dire que les choses vont
pas se faire immédiatement ou c'est un
report du projet c'est souvent c'est pas
vécu comme un échec au contraire ça
permet de rebondir sur d'autres projets
merci donc à tous les deux on va
continuer cette chronique de l'Echo
claire on va juste faire peut-être une
petite pause auparavant avant de revenir
sur le concours talent de la création de
la BGE avec un autre invité de ce soir
c'est la 15e édition d'ailleurs on va
revenir sur la contestation qui gronde
du côté des salariés de l'automobile PSA
comme Renault qui se mobilise devant les
plans sociaux en début de semaine les
employés de Flins de la marque au
losanges étaient en grève je vous
propose de revoir ce sujet d'Anthony
rech
la colère monte chez les salariés
Renault de Flins ce mardi matin ils ont
effectué leur première opération coup de
poing aux abords du site bloquant la
circulation pendant près d'une heure
leur message est clair ils vont se
battre contre le plan de compétitivité
annoncée par la direction qui prévoit
entre 7500 et 8260 suppressions
d'emplois non plus de la moitié en
départ naturel
aujourd'hui c'est un avertissement
demain vous verrez on est on est capable
on est déterminé on est capable de se
battre comme des lions pour empêcher le
chômage de ravager la vie de millions de
gens pendant que les autres s'en mettent
plein les poches on est capable d'aller
très très loin personne ne le soupçonne
on est déterminé selon les syndicats la
marque losange aurait réalisé un profit
de 786 millions d'euros sur les six
premiers mois de 2012 pour la première
fois depuis l'annonce du plan les agents
de maîtrise se réjou en mouvement cette
révolte s'adresse aussi au gouvernement
on voudrait faire passer ce message
absolument de Bourg parce que au monde
bourre effectivement on a vu qu'il
chantait à l'émission mais nous pour
nous monde bourse et paroles et paroles
les paroles il a des très belles paroles
mais bon il a quand même 15% enfin
Renault et l'État en 15% et on pense que
de parole il faut qu'ils passent aux
actes les salariés étaient près de 500
ce matin réunis devant l'usine Renault
de Flins et les syndicats donnent déjà
rendez-vous mardi prochain 5 février
pour une nouvelle action coup de poing